tu peux avoir accès à la musique en
local c'est à ton petit con ce que tu
files sur connect et tu vas pouvoir
gérer ta musique directement ici des
raccourcis mais évidemment
calculatrice août pavé numérique est ce
qu'on va avoir vraiment intéressante
[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui on est à berlin
et aujourd'hui on est directement aux
media days de l'ifa
de la marque asus que les sites tous
asus on a beaucoup parlé avec les
smartphones les iphone 5 5 z5 light et
compagnie hélas aujourd'hui asus nous
présente plutôt des ordinateurs voilà
donc on va lui faire un petit tour vous
allez voir c'est plutôt coup il ya des
choses très sympas qui se passe ici là
toute une gamme qui est très large tout
est marqué ici dans le placard mais
voyez tout en avant-première ce
extraordinaire donc on va aller faire un
petit tour je vous montre un peu les
différents modèles honda regardez à quoi
il ressemble et puis on les déteste aura
probablement plus tard peut-être pas
tous mais peut-être quelques-uns dont je
vous invite à faire une chose bien
évidemment c'est à vous abonner activée
[Musique]
on est avec jonathan de la vue jonathan
voilà donc aujourd'hui vous allez
présenter plein de produits est ce que
tu peux me faire un petit condensé pour
vraiment votre média restituer parce que
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de produits
je me perds un peu c'est vrai que cette
édition 2008 de l'ifa pour nous à
l'importante parce qu'on va là la
concentrer sur la partie pc notamment
sur les ebooks
comme tu sais on a une gamme assez large
de produits dont la téléphonie qu'on a à
dracé adressé notamment bob mobile world
congress ans avec les iphone
lorsqu'on se comptent sur les haines
bouquet notre gamme ultra portables et
sur laquelle on apporte beaucoup
d'innovations c'est une gamme qui a déjà
bien vécu mais qui continue constamment
d'innover aujourd'hui avec des nouveaux
châssis
donc nous on a principalement
aujourd'hui la gamme z groupe composé de
jeunes 13 14 et 15 sur les tailles
d'écran avec un pouce pour ça c'est au
15 mars et le 15 à 14 6 ème ou sinon
c'était quand même un écart qui est
beaucoup plus grand emprunt de 15 kg 15
ans entre le 13 et 14 mars et 13 3 14
avec 1,6 on a l'habitude de dire 13 14 à
lévis en marche et que ce soit le ratio
16 9ème à garder qui fait qu'à un moment
donné tu es obligé d'avoir sur le 15
pouces quelque chose de plus grande
envergure
qu'est ce qui est assez dingue c'est que
si tu prends un tout va garde la toux et
les deux c'est vraiment flagrant si tu
prends un truc 14h15
ouais 15 et 13 13 si tu prends un 13
pouces
aujourd'hui on va dire quatre des six
mois tu serait quasiment sur un
encombrement autour de ça apprendre la
lysine book fip pour aller chercher de
la versatilité 60 tout à fait ça
c'est un jeune de 13 clip mais des êtres
f1 pour avoir un maximum de d'écran
utile effectivement comme certains clips
qu'il se tourne à 360 passer en mode
tablette
et puis on a des in book pro sur
lesquels effectivement comme son nom
l'indiqué dernier un petit peu au top
des fonctionnalités donc là on est ce
qu'on appelle top spec avec l'ensemble
des spectacles qu'on peut avoir du ssd
évidemment un core i7 beaucoup de ram et
surtout de l'innovation encore puisqu'on
va intégrer un screen pad
donc comme on a pu le voir ensemble à
c'est un second écran on va intégrer à
la place finalement du pavé de pavé
tactile conseil votre sourire mais c'est
également un second écran qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser
comment surmonter cran mais également
comme un raccourci pour beaucoup
d'application ici c'est le zenbook
14 donc on retrouve un peu le design
avec quelque part de sont ici et qui
donne un petit peu niveau couleur la
fameuse charnière car gaulliste
et la petite innovation évidemment
puisque celui ci c'est le procès le
thinkpad
viens ici se positionner donc là tu peux
avoir accès à la musique en local ces
dates ans qui compte spotify belge se
connectent et tu vas pouvoir gérer ta
musique directement ici des raccourcis
évidemment de calculatrice ou de pavé
numérique est ce qu'on va avoir vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'on a commencé à
développer des partenariats notamment
avec microsoft pour la partie office
contre valence et hongroises ton
excellent temps pour en reprendre
l'ensemble des raccourcis par exemple de
gestion paragraphe du texte
ils vont être ici il a sélectionné un
texte tu va choisir la couleur
directement là qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que déjà elle est
entièrement customisable donc tu vois tu
peux aller chercher de bons écrans thur
n'est pas petit point d'écran il faut la
considérer comme un deuxième écran comme
si tu avais tu en es tu au moniteur sur
le côté je peux prendre mon écran
principal regarder une vidéo youtube ici
la prendre la serbie c'est ici qu'on
continue et regardez la vidéo
et puis travailler ce qu'il veut pour
les gens qui te regarde c'est cool tu
peux aussi pleurer ton téléphone en fait
indirectement wifi etc ni tu vas voir ta
faim de téléphone surtout ici et pouvoir
gérer cette application téléphones sont
inscrits par un public tout l'avait
lancée il n'y a pas très longtemps alors
ça ça a été annoncé au computex
donc en juin
notamment sur un 15 pouces aujourd'hui
on apporte sur le marché le 14 pouces
alors qu'un nouveau design et c'est
surtout une technologie dans laquelle on
croit beaucoup
où on investit dans ce type de
technologies notamment sur l'oder
douaire mais également sur le software
microsoft et partenaires nous avons
effectivement l'ensemble de raccourcis
sur la suite office et on essaye
d'invités développeurs à développer un
maximum d'applications pour rendre et
finalement les usages ce skin path pas
tout à fait un tweet y fasse que ça
vraiment génial parce que ça rajoute
effectivement est-ce que l'écran est
tactile ou pas tout à fait donc on à
l'écran tactile donc on peut ensuite
naviguer directement votre clavier notre
souris et on a en plus le screen pack
permet de rajouter des applications en
plus c'est juste super c'est vraiment
bien mais en fait on se rend compte que
sur le pc il est qu'on manque
d'innovation on se disait belle
innovation 6 sur d'autres produits et
tablettes les smartphones
on se rend compte que c'est un outil le
pc qu'on continue à utiliser au
quotidien on en a besoin et donc on se
dit pourquoi pas essayer de proposer du
sort de nouveau sur le pc parce que tu
trouves que le marché du pc n'étaient
pas pas moribond mais une image un peu
négative de manque d'innovation de
choses un peu classique par rapport à
d'autres secteurs comme le smartphone
qui sont un peu plus plus innovants en
fait on peut dire que la la hype un
petit peu transférés vers toute cette
nouvelle technologie notamment les
tablettes pendant un moment on a vu que
s'ils retombaient les smartphones oui
beaucoup beaucoup d'acteurs ouais c'est
un nouvel outil on se rend compte que le
pc que beaucoup annoncent est mort et
continue de survivre parce qu'on en a
besoin
et peut-être que moins d'attention est
est sur le pc sinon on se dit que c'est
dommage parce que c'est un outil qu'on
étudie ce tous les jours et autant
essayer de continuer d'optimiser et le
screen pad en est un vrai exemple
ouais notre petit trackpad ans
l'utilisent depuis des années et on dit
ban on n'y touche pas c'est tout ce qui
fonctionne pourquoi pas finalement
essayé de nous proposer quelque chose de
nouveau c'est une belle innovation
alors du coup vous avez des produits qui
s'adresse à tout un chacun
on va commencer je dirais avec des
produits les plus abordables
ça va être la gamme
ebooks il vaut bola ok donc la gagne au
bout de la gamme un petit peu mystream
chez nous qui peut aller de 2 300
jusqu'à 800 900 euros qui après la gamme
dizaines de bouquets la gamme un petit
peu et litres les ultraportables placé
pour des gens qui ont envie d'avoir un
très bel outil qui est surtout très
mobile puisque ce sont des produits
comme on a pu le voir très fin très
léger on se parle de 1 kg donc on va
avoir des outils qui servent à la
mobilité
génial et après on va monter en gamme le
plus haut de gamme c'est la gamme pro
exactement les haines book pro sur
lesquels on a commencé déjà sur le 15
pouces à lancer des produits sur le 14
pouces également qui arrive
wen en montrent un petit peu plus en
terme de prix on pourra faire un recap
si besoin mais tout n'est pas encore
annoncée mais on est sur des outils qui
sont qui sont faites pour répondre à
tous les besoins
ok génial et bombay tout merci parce que
tu pas autre chose à résister focus sur
quelque chose en particulier
ce qu'on peut évoquer et on l'a vu aussi
ne le skin pad on pense que c'est le
futur
et comme on la surnomme indique 13 14 et
fait encore sur le cas puisque le 15 a
déjà un pavé numérique
on propose là une sorte de mini screen
pad on appelle le number pad où on a le
clavier
le pavé numérique pardon qui vient à la
place du segment du pavé tactile laisse
pour pouvoir avoir toujours un chiffre à
portée de main même sur un tout petit
chef sur 15 pouces est là encore la
place même en optimisant de m un pavé
numérique
c'est pas le cas sur le 14 et 13 tu la
mets sur le 10ème tour exactement
donc là on essaye de rendre le compact
tout en intégrant encore un pavé
numérique parce qu'il ya quand même de
la demande pour pallier à l'absence du
pavé numérique
hop on le propose de manière digitale
sur pavé tactile avec sa gamme sur le 13
décembre 14 exactement
tu peux l'avoir en option nous on marché
français on va essayer de mettre un
maximum parce qu'on est convaincu que
c'est une bonne innovation c'est pas
compliqué c'est facile d'usagé qu'ils
activent qu'ils désactivent là tu peux
avoir ton compassé on a mis les petites
fonctions de calcul c'était un fan de la
calculette pour pouvoir l'utiliser
merci en tout cas belle innovation
illustre continue avec une face à ses
pairs écoute merci à toi et puis on va
continuer on continuera à parler d'un
juge par la suite parce qu'effectivement
liés à ces ordis qui sont présents donc
j'espère qu'on pourra et testé il ya
aussi du smartphone il appelle faisant
que dassault on reste connectés
merci à toi merci
[Musique]
bénédicte un petit peu vous avez
derrière moi l'endroit où se passe le
media days sassus part sur un roof top
on est en plein coeur de berlin dans les
quartiers sympathique et juste derrière
moi vous avez vous voyez tout est un peu
hop vous avez un petit zoo voilà c'est
ça le côté zoo vous avez des petites
bêtes qui se baladent qu'est-ce qu'on a
là bas des singes voilà pas si vous
voyez un peu les singes en bas on a pas
mal de petits trucs mois le quartier
plutôt sympa alors ici on est
extrêmement bien reçue
vous avez au minéral à volonté j'ai eu
le fruit de quoi manger trop board quoi
se restaurer voilà pour cette
présentation de asus lors des media days
alors point un sens est sous embargo
au moment où je le tourne c'est à dire
que c'est pas le rôle de certains tout
de suite il faut attendre la
présentation officielle donc je n'en
parle pas sur les réseaux sociaux mais
en tout cas voilà donc dites moi vous ça
vous intéresse qu'on parle comme ça
aussi d'ordinateurs je parle beaucoup de
smartphones on va continuer à le faire
parce que je trouve que le smartphone
c'est l'objet technologique que tout le
monde a avec soin mais je trouve ça
aussi cool de pouvoir parler par exemple
de d'ordinateurs parce que les
ordinateurs on les utilise aussi
beaucoup par les tablettes des pas mal
de choses donc dites moi si ça vous
intéresse qu on parle comme ça tu fais
la gueule qu'on parle comme ça
d'ordinateurs véritable marque et tout
ça en commentaire qui va me donner votre
avis je vous invite bien évidemment
rester qualité parce qu'on va parler
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'ordinateurs de pas mal de choses de
nouveautés de smartphones il ya aussi
plein plein de tact bonnes choses qui
arrivent donc vous invite à faire une
seule chose c'est à vous abonner et bien
évidemment à rester connectés tout
[Musique]